RETO MEIER: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
Today on the app clinic, we'll
be reviewing the App Clinic.
RETO MEIER: We're turning the
microscope and ourselves to
take a look at what we do what
we do and we want to take this
runaway freight train
of app awesomeness.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We'll also be
giving a shout out to some of
our favorite apps and mourning
the absence of
the giant fake phone.
This is the App Clinic.
RETO MEIER: Each week, on the
App Clinic, Ian and I review a
series of apps in a particular
category.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Lately we've been
digging a little deeper,
highlighting some of this
technical challenges involved
for people trying to
build apps that
fit into that category.
RETO MEIER: And at the end
of each episode, we offer
patients a set of prescriptions
that we believe
will help them take their
app to the next level.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Then, the
following Tuesday, in this
sort of circle of awesomeness
we have going, Roman, Nick,
and Adam take another pass from
a design perspective.
They'll offer some insights into
how to make the apps more
consistent with the design
aesthetic of Android and even
create some screen mocks for
apps that offer some practical
ideas for how to make your
apps more intuitive.
RETO MEIER: The idea behind
both shows is to take the
conversations we on the Android
Developer Relations
team have every day
and hold them in
more of a public forum.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And with
less swear words.
Our team's mission is to help
developers create magical
experiences.
We want to make Android a better
platform for users and,
of course, make a better
platform for developers, make
it more successful.
RETO MEIER: And to that end,
we'll be shifting our focus to
be a little more technical.
We'll be looking not just at
the features that the apps
that we look at it but also
how they're implemented.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We're
not just going to
look at features either.
We're going to be looking at
things like efficiency, and
how to make your UI buttery
smooth, and best practices in
general that exist for apps in
whatever category we happen to
be reviewing.
RETO MEIER: Each episode is
going to have a strong
technical focus.
There will be plenty of code
snippets that are going to
show you how to do the things
that we've been talking about
all episode.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We also wanted
a way to reward the app
developers, the ones we love
like Tasks, Hipmunk, IM, and
Camera FX Pro.
These guys followed
our advice.
They implemented the
improvements that we talked
about, and they took their
apps to the next level.
RETO MEIER: And so, to that end,
we're creating the App
Clinic's Pure Android
collections.
This is going to be a collection
of apps that Ian
and I are going to handpick, and
each of which, we believe,
offers the users a magical
experience in some way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now any of the
apps that we review on the App
Clinic will be eligible for
consideration to include in
this collection.
So I think the big question
is, how do you
get your app nominated?
RETO MEIER: It is indeed.
So if you have any questions
about the details that we're
discussing here, let us know
on the the G+ event, or on
YouTube, or however you're
watching the event now and
we'll try and to get back to
them at the end of the show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Engineer Dan is busy checking
out the old--
that wasn't supposed
to happen, OK.
RETO MEIER: [LAUGH]
That's all right.
Switch that to the background,
if you would, Daniel.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There
you go, OK.
RETO MEIER: So why
don't I jump back
and then jump forward.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
RETO MEIER: [LAUGH]
Perfect, well, not
quite as perfect.
That's not quite the
right one, Daniel.
There isn't one for us behind?
Interesting.
DAN: Let me--
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
Woohoo!
All right, OK, now play
that thing, and
it's going to be awesome.
RETO MEIER: All right.
Boom.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah!
So how do you go about
RETO MEIER: Nominating?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
DAN: Sorry, guys.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's OK.
RETO MEIER: It's all good.
So we've created a Trello
board on which we take
nominations for both
the categories
you'd like us to review.
And you can login with your
Google account, so it's pretty
straightforward.
And then anyone can add a
comment to the nominations
card on the proposed
categories list.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now just in case
you didn't see that URL as it
was flying by, the URL is
bit.ly/AppClinicTrello,
capital A, capital C, capital
T. So we're going to go
through and create new cards
for each nomination.
You can vote for them.
And once a new category has got
sufficient votes that we
can make an interesting show
out of it, we're going to
create a new list and--
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And so then, for each list, so
what you are going to end up
with is one list which is all
categories which you vote on
and add your comments for the
categories you'd like.
And then we're going to go
through and create a new list
for each of those categories.
And that's why we're looking
for nominations for apps.
So the top card on each of those
category lists is going
to be a place where you can
comment and say, hey, please
nominate my app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right,
so we can just see over
here would be the--
so this is where you are going
to nominate categories that
you want to talk about.
RETO MEIER: That's right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And then once
we've got a category that
everybody wants to talk about,
like Halloween apps, our most
successful category ever, then
you put cards in there.
And it works a lot like
Moderator except there's no
down votes, and you can see
a lot more on one screen.
RETO MEIER: Exactly, and so this
gives us a chance to see,
you know, what are the
categories that people really
want us to look at.
And gives you a chance to see
ahead of time what's coming.
So rather than just having to
keep track of what's happening
next week, you can see that,
hey, we're social apps as well
in a few weeks' time.
So I want to make sure that my
social app gets nominated.
And then you can help get people
to put vote them up,
and so on, and so forth.
So we're going to create
the cards.
At the moment, you guys
can only create
comments and votes.
And then, a week before each App
Clinic, we're going like
three or four of the apps that
we want to take a look at.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And we'll
generally try and select the
apps with the highest
number of votes.
But we want to increase the
chances that the apps that we
look out will make it into our
Pure Android collection.
So we are going to do a little
bit of editorial work.
We're going to look favorably
on apps that are
self-nominated as well as those
that pass some of our
most basic tests.
Now I'm actually going to break
in here and say that,
based on some the feedback
we've gotten from our
partners, we will probably
move to an entirely
self-nominated system.
So you will need to make sure
that the app developer is
involved with the app that
you're nominating if you're
not the developer yourself.
RETO MEIER: That's right.
And the reason why we want to
do that is, well, for two
reasons, and, mainly, it's
because we want to work with
developers who are
really interested
in hearing our feedback.
We're going to be
pretty candid.
I think anyone who's watched
the show before knows that.
It's always, hopefully,
constructive criticism, but we
want to make sure that, if we're
putting this advice out
there that the people who we're
giving it to want to
hear it and want to be able to
take advantages of what we're
telling them.
So speaking of tests.
Let's talk about how you go from
App Clinic patient to a
Pure Android member.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So we'll start
by putting each app through
our basic QA checklist, which
you may recognize as the
recently finished Android core
app quality guidelines.
Now this is the low bar.
It basically just demonstrates
that your app runs, and
doesn't crash, and follows the
most basic set of quality
guidelines we can think of.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
We'd like to think that you've
already run your apps through
this checklist before you
publish it on Google Play, let
alone submit it to us
to have a look at.
So we might use this as a way to
filter out some of the apps
which aren't quite ready
for us for review yet.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Now after we do the basic
checklist, we'll look at how
your app runs on
tablet devices.
You know that this is the year
of the Android tablet.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Not to be confused
with 10 years from
now, which is the year
of Linux desktop.
RETO MEIER: That's right.
I've been waiting for
that for so long.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right?
Now we're going to use the
tablet app quality guidelines
as a guide there.
RETO MEIER: And it's important
that your app not only work
but it works well on all devices
so that means phones
and tablets.
So we'll be giving it a good
going over on a phone, on a
7-inch, and a 10-inch tablet
before we consider it for part
of the Pure Android
collection.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Are we're
going to do
12-inch, 15-inch tablets?
RETO MEIER: We may do it.
We'll play it by ear.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now the last deal
breaker is going to be
your feature graphic.
Every app in a category needs
to have a feature graphic in
order to be included.
RETO MEIER: And that's not just
us being difficult, it's
actually a technical
requirement.
So if you're nominating your app
for review and you want it
to be considered for entry to
the Pure Android collection,
you need to have a
feature graphic.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In fact, we're
actually going to take a look
at all of your assets--
feature graphics, icons, and
even your app descriptions.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, and then Nick
and Roman and Adam will
go through each of the apps
through the prism of the
Android Design Guide on
Tuesday's Android Design in
Action, offering some
suggestions for how to improve
your user experience of each
of the apps from a design
perspective as well as the
category in general and the
usual user experience
tips that these guys
are happy to provide.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now remember,
we're not expecting every app
that we look out to be perfect
from the first time we see it.
RETO MEIER: No, and the point
of the App Clinic isn't to
find the very best, most popular
app in each category.
There are other featured lists
that do exactly that.
We're developer advocates, so
what makes it a good day for
us is when we find a way to help
a developer take their
good app and make
it a better app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So don't worry if
we review your app and give
you a bunch of constructive
criticism.
The very fact we reviewed your
app means that it has some
interesting functionality that
we think needs to be
represented on Google Play.
Giving you constructive
criticism gives you an
opportunity to take that great
functionality and turn it into
a wonderful app.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
What we're really hoping to
create is a knowledge base of
information that helps not just
the apps that we review
but everyone who watches and all
the Android app developers
to create really magical
experiences for their users.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which is awesome
because you are a magician,
and you will be showing us
how to make things magic.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And I may get into a little
bit of trouble from the
magician's trade union for
giving away some of the
secrets, but ultimately
I think it's worth it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what?
What's really magic?
I can wave my hands and make
the office turn green.
RETO MEIER: Oh, no,
I can though.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh
yeah, you can.
Whatever.
Wow, the one time we do want
the lights to screw up.
RETO MEIER: I can't
make it go weird.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Darn.
Oh well.
Good job Dan, engineer Dan.
OK, so what we're really trying
to do is we want to
hear back from you.
We want to hear back from the
developers whose apps we're
reviewing, and we want to hear
back throughout the entire
cycle of going through and
applying it the ideas we've
had, rejecting some, accepting
others, going through
technical challenges.
That entire process of improving
the apps, we'd
really like to work with you
closely and hopefully record
that process.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely, I mean,
a lot of what we're
doing here-- it's really easy
for us to stand here, flick
through your app and tell you
what you should be doing
differently.
But we're really interested to
hear what happens when you try
to take that advice.
And it's a case of hey, we
thought about that, and we
chose not to do it
for a reason.
Or we took your advice, we tried
to do it, and we ran
into these roadblocks.
That's really important and
useful information.
So we're going to continue to
regularly broadcast Developers
Strike Back.
And that's your opportunity, for
the developers whose apps
that we've reviewed,
to respond to us.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, rather than
following up the week after
the App Clinic, we're asking you
to let us know when you've
got something you'd
like to share.
RETO MEIER: And we're really
looking forward to hearing
some real war stories around the
implementation suggestions
or implementation of
the suggestions
that we've given you.
So both tales of success like,
yeah, we tried to do this
thing and now our list views
are buttery smooth, or
frustration like, yeah, we try
to implement this skeuomorphic
design alternative and it
really didn't work out.
And our users in our AB testing,
and our beta releases
just showed that it
wasn't working.
So we want to hear both ends.
What are we getting right?
What are we getting wrong?
What are you finding easy?
What are you finding
difficult?
So we can then feed that back
into our system as well and
try to come up with ways to make
the things that we think
are good easier for
you guys to do.
So that is hopefully going to
save other developers pains as
they try and improve
their apps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now once you've
been reviewed, let us know
whenever you think you're one
step closer to Pure Android
and we'll take another look.
If we notice something that's
particularly cool or
particularly challenging, we'll
invite you to Developers
Strike Back to talk about
what you've done.
RETO MEIER: And they once your
apps is Pure Android magic,
we'll induct you into the Pure
Android collection, which will
hopefully offer you some extra
downloads but, more
importantly, will give
you an opportunity to
brag to your friends.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Of course.
Now we're really looking forward
to the new format.
And we hope that it helps
provide some recognition, and
motivation, and hopefully some
income to the developers who
are brave enough to offer up
your apps for public scrutiny.
So with that I think we're
going to open it up to
questions from the internet.
RETO MEIER: Yeah,
so is there--
do you know, Dan?
Is there any questions from any
of the people who may have
tuned in to let us know
what they need to do?
DAN: No, but we do have one
comment that says, "You guys
are incredibly lucky to be
employed the way you and your
job is basically just criticize
someone else's work.
And they do all the work.
So good for you guys."
RETO MEIER: There is
an aspect to that.
I won't lie.
But I mean, in truth, it's not
really about the criticism.
What we're really trying to do
is find out more ways to be
able to help you guys
to build great apps.
We're really trying to make it
easier for developers to build
the sorts of apps that we
want to use and that
people want to use.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you've got
to remember that this is only
a small part of our jobs.
Most of the time, what we're
doing is writing all the
documentation on
developer.android.com,
creating the tutorials, writing
sample code, and
writing things like the app
compatibility library.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So if there are
specific technical issues or
problems with the operating
system, or with the framework
that are preventing you from
creating a great app, it's our
job to help you surmount
those obstacles.
And whether that's by creating
a compatibility library, by
writing a better tutorial,
by documenting things
differently, or by going in
and fixing issues with the
operating system itself,
that's our job.
So we want to hear from you so
that we can do our job better.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean, that's a key
part of what we do.
It's like, we do stand here.
And in this show in particular,
it's all about
trying to help developers build
something better and, in
doing so, criticizing those who
haven't done the best that
they can do.
But really, the reverse part
of our job is taking all of
that feedback from you guys.
And that's why we really mean
it when you say, we tried to
do what you said, and we
couldn't for whatever reason.
We want to hear that, not just
because it changes the message
that we can tell other people,
but so that we can go back to
the framework team, so that we
can go back to our sample
code, to the support library,
to the developer tools and
figure out ways to really
make that process
easier for you guys.
A lot of companies would call
the role that we have tech
evangelists.
And at Google we call
ourselves advocates.
And the reason for that is
because we really care about
having that reverse lens.
We want to be able to take
the suggestions and the
experiences that you guys have
and feed it back into the
system to trying and
improve that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I mean, we
sit right in the middle of the
framework team.
On one side we've got the video
and media guys, and
graphics, and then we've got
all the windowing, and
support, and USB, and just,
basically, in a
horseshoe around us.
And you will often find us going
around to those people
to either ask what it
is they intended.
So I'll say, Dianne Hackborn,
for instance--
there is this perfectly
legitimate request that I just
got from a developer, and I
really think that we can't
satisfy it correctly.
And then, because Dianne is
smarter than me, she'll
usually say, well, actually,
they've sort of
approached it wrong.
Here's the way the system
is supposed to work.
And here's the way that
makes more sense.
Or one of the video guys will
be like, wow, we don't have
that's that feature right, so
here's what you're going have
to do to work around it.
Or here's when we think we're
going to have it.
Can you collect some
more information?
Can you find more partners
that need this?
We have these interactions
all the time.
So yes, our job is incredibly
awesome.
RETO MEIER: Yes, there is no
debate about that aspect.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And yes, we do
criticize lots and lots of
things all the time, which I
think, if you've ever worked
in or near a developer relations
team, you'll know
it's pretty much par
for the course.
But--
RETO MEIER: If you like to
complain, it's a pretty good
career path to take.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The criticism
isn't part of our job.
It's usually what we just do
over beers on Friday night.
The real task that's before us
and the most difficult and
complicated, but satisfying,
thing that we need to do is to
make this a better platform
for developers.
And part of that is making it a
better platform, and part of
that is making sure that you,
as developers, know how good
the platform is already.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, exactly, I
mean, I think that's what has
driven a lot of what we're doing
on the App Clinic is a
frustration of saying, look,
here's an app that is really,
really good, but it's not as
successful as it could be.
And some of the reasons for
that is that the developer
just may not know what they
could be taking advantage of.
And so that's really what we're
talking about with the
new direction for the App Clinic
is to try and drive it
more and more into that
technical realm.
So that we're not really going
to be that focused on a
feature by feature
breakdown and
comparison between the apps.
We're really looking at, OK, so
for all of the apps in the
category, here are the key
things that you need to know.
And for these specific apps,
here are a bunch of new things
that you could do to make this
app even more compelling, to
increasing engagement, increase
downloads, and
hopefully lead to increased
monetization however you
choose to monetize your apps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The other thing to
say we really need to bring
up is what motivates us to
change the show in this way.
And it's because it is very easy
for us to point out, you
know, oh look, there's the
menu button of shame.
Here's an action bar
that doesn't work
the way you'd think.
I mean, that stuff is
incredibly trivial.
But we realized that most of the
problems that people are
having, if they are truly
interested in making great
Android apps, don't have
anything to do with that.
They've already read the
design guidelines.
They've already sort of decided
what they're going to
follow and what they're
going to change.
But they may be doing something
like we brought up
last week, where you're
requiring the user to type in
a long username and password in
order to even use the app,
which, as we know, reduces
engagement.
So we want to make sure that
we're showing the best
practices for things like that
and also trying to solve
common problems that affect many
different applications.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
I think another important part
of what we're trying to do,
particularly with this show, but
I think across developer
relations--
the Android platform iterates
pretty frequently.
So there's a lot of new features
that come out at a
rate of, it seems like
at least every six
months these days.
And so we know that, obviously,
it's our job to
know what all those
things are.
And so we keep track of that.
It always seems like, wow, all
of this stuff is so obvious.
We've seen it for so long.
Why isn't everyone doing it?
Unsurprisingly, not every
developer spends every minute
of their day hitting
F5, refreshing the
developer.android.com site to
find out what new API--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Although some
of you do, and we
know who you are.
RETO MEIER: And thank you.
Those page views are
paying our bills.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
RETO MEIER: So a big part of
this is, for apps like one of
the apps that we looked at just
last week, Grocery IQ.
Great app, wonderful design,
a lot of thought and
effort went into it.
But I think the developers
of that app just haven't
necessarily been able to keep
track of all the fancy new
features that are available,
which can make that app even
more compelling, even
more exciting.
And so a big part, I think of
what we're going to be telling
our developers and our audience
is some of the cool
new functions, the new features,
the new APIs that
you can use to help improve your
apps and make them even
better for the newest
Android device.
And they're kind of a
particularly important audience.
That may not be the biggest
number, but they are people
who tend to drive engagement,
and more importantly, the ones
which tend to set trends
amongst their friends.
So if you get those early
adopters and get them to love
your app, they're the ones who
are going to tell their
friends, their family, about
this cool new app that they
should be using.
So there's an opportunity there
and hopefully that's
something that we can help
you guys drive towards.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
The other thing to keep in mind
is that, last year, when
we started talking about action
bars and buttons of
shame, it was all sort of new.
And if you were approaching your
app from a market share
position, looking at devices and
OS versions and trying to
hit the largest sweet spot, it
probably wasn't a particularly
compelling story.
That has pretty much changed.
The tide has turned, and we're
now going from the old
gingerbread world, which was
heavily focused on varying UI
patterns, per-device UI,
per-manufacturer UI, lots of
different buttons, lots of
different assets that you
either had to use or ignore
at your peril.
Now we're in the ICS and Jelly
Bean world, where things are
considerably better designed
from the OS standpoint.
There are design patterns that
affect every device on the
market and the OS itself has
gotten significantly faster.
So any poorly performing
application or poorly designed
application sticks out
like sore thumb.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, and you never
want to stick out for
the wrong reasons.
You want to be an app which
sticks out for being the
shiniest, the fanciest,
the newest--
not the one which looks
like it was designed
several years ago.
And so that's a big part,
particularly of what the
Android Design in Action team
are going to be looking at on
Tuesdays, is really trying to
figure out ways that apps,
particularly apps which have
a unique look and feel, can
maintain that uniqueness while
still being consistent with
the platform overall.
And I think that's a really
important part of what we're
all trying to focus on, is,
we don't want to create
homogeneity across all apps.
We don't want everything
to look the
same and act the same.
But we do want to make it easy
for users to understand how to
explore the features,
how to get started.
So hopefully what we'll end up
with in this collection, what
we really envisage, is something
that we can point to
to say, hey, if you want to
build something awesome on
Android that users are going
to love, that fits into the
platform while still having its
own uniqueness and rich
features, check out
these apps.
And so that's really the guiding
principle behind the
apps that we're going to choose,
not necessarily the
one which has the most downloads
but the one which,
we think, sort of highlights
what's possible on Android.
So users and developers alike
have something to aim for in
terms of what they should
be aspiring towards.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now that's a very
long answer to a comment
that wasn't actually
a question.
RETO MEIER: Very true.
That could have been a dig, but
we'll take a dig and turn
it into a 15-minute answer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
And next week, we're going
to answer all our YouTube
comments from last week.
RETO MEIER: [LAUGH]
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm kidding.
RETO MEIER: Did we get any other
questions, or any actual
questions or comments which we
can similarly comment on?
IAN NI-LEWIS: On G+
or on YouTube?
DAN: Yeah, so we've got a lot of
thank yous in the comments
on YouTube today just
for having these
lives shows ever week.
People really appreciate the
fact that they can interact
with you guys for even a
short amount of time.
And they know that you're
actually really busy, and that
dig earlier about not really
doing anything but criticizing
other people's work is just
a one off comment.
RETO MEIER: Well, you know,
that's the thing.
It would be pretty ironic if
we did spend any amount of
time criticizing other apps
and were unable to take
criticism ourselves.
So we definitely want to
hear that feedback.
And if things like--
a good example, we heard a lot
of people talking about the
fact that they really loved
the action bar.
And they wanted to use a pattern
like that in their app
but that it was non-trivial
to implement.
And if we're going to complain
about people not doing it the
right way, shouldn't
we make it easier?
And so that's something which
leads back into teams within
our team, in fact, going out
and trying to build some of
those things, put them in
the support library
for you guys to use.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Although oddly
enough, in this weird
coincidence, yesterday we got
two separate emails asking,
why did the menu go away
in API level 11?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, and
it's interesting.
I think a lot of the times
what we see is this clash
almost, where we have an
internal team deciding that
this is the way that the
platform is going to go and
external developers going, well
actually, I kind of disagree.
And sometimes it can
go both ways.
We saw with the dashboard
patent, something which we
were promoting back in the
Gingerbread days, it didn't
really work.
Particularly once you put it
onto a tablet, it's like, well
actually, this isn't so great.
So that back and forth is a
big part of what ends up
driving future directions for
things like Android design.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, and you'll
see too that the Android
designers have taken feedback
from elsewhere.
For instance, there is now a
design pattern for the drawer
pattern where there
wasn't before.
The nice thing is, once it's
codified as a design standard,
you know, basically, they
didn't create the drawer
pattern, but they did look
at the way everybody had
implemented it and tried to pick
the particular type of
implementation that fit the best
with the platform, and
with user friendliness, and
usability in general.
And so now there's a pattern.
And it's not the way that, for
instance, the original Google+
app did it.
RETO MEIER: No
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's closer to the
way the original YouTube
app did it.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, i think it's
pretty close to the way
YouTube shows.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The Google+ app
is now updated, actually.
And yeah, it's actually
a little more usable.
So that sort of thing is
actually extremely valuable to
us, when we hear that there's a
particular UI pattern that's
either absent or getting
in the way of
making your app great.
Now obviously, if you're the
type of designer, and I know
that this exists--
if your boss is carrying some
other type of phone, and they
come in they say, we hate
your design because it
doesn't look right.
And you say, no, it's a perfect
Android design.
And they're like, well, it
doesn't look like my
smartphone, we know
that can be tough.
But in general, if you're trying
to make an Android
design and it doesn't work for
whatever reason, we want to
hear about it because
we want to fix as
many of those we can.
And anyone who's willing to work
with us on a continual
basis and implement our
suggestions and make our
design better is very likely
to get some help from us.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I think that's an important part
of what we're trying to
offer here.
And really, the justification
for why we've sort of rebooted
our App Clinic series today is
because we want to make it
clear that the apps that we do
talk about, we're not just
putting you up there like
a pinata to take hits
and then move on.
We really want to hear
back from you.
We want to know what are you
doing, what worked, what
didn't work, what was harder
than it should've been?
We're really interested to know,
if we say, oh, we think
you should just change this
button over here slightly, and
you're like, yeah man, that took
like two days of work.
And we had to hire a designer
for a half a day.
We need to know.
That's the sort of thing which
we can really do actions on.
So it needs to be a two-way
street here.
This is an opportunity that I
think some of you guys will
find quite useful, and,
certainly, I would've back in
the days when I was writing
code every day instead of
doing developer relations is
hearing that advice and being
able to really speak to people
who are providing it, and get
that input as to well how can
I do this, and these are the
struggles that I've had.
And so this is us putting
ourselves out there and giving
you guys the opportunity to have
that back and forth, let
us know what's working,
what's not
working, and ask us questions.
And that's really, when we're
talking about taking technical
deep dives, that's what we
want to spend the time on
these show doing, is showing you
exactly how to implement
difficult things and creating
as much content
around that as we can.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And in general,
what we're going to try and do
is keep the show to a half an
hour but have some question
time afterwards.
So we'll still schedule
an hour from our day.
Now we may actually pre-record
some of the
segments of the show--
RETO MEIER: Only those which
don't affect the outcome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
But we will always be here
live for questions at the
appointed time.
Just go ahead and type
them into YouTube, or
type them into G+.
It looks like YouTube's
probably the preferred
scenario right now because
that's what Dan's got up on
the screen.
RETO MEIER: But we're going to
try and do a lot better as
well when it comes to
responding to this
stuff in real time.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh there you go,
Dan's got that one up.
RETO MEIER: He's
got it all up.
He's got it under control.
IAN NI-LEWIS: He is
on top of things.
Well, let us know.
So Dan, is there anything else
that stands out as a question?
DAN: Yeah, one of our usual
viewers, [? FunnerGoat ?],
wants to know where the Pure
Android collection is going to
be posted to.
RETO MEIER: So we'll have more
details on exactly where you
can find all of this stuff once
we've got a few apps to
put in there.
So we're going to take a quick
look back across some of the
apps that we've reviewed--
don't know what happened
to my tongue there--
over the last few weeks.
I know Camera ZOOM FX have just
released an exciting new
update which does a lot of the
things which the Android
Design in Action
team suggested.
So we're going to probably, this
week, spend a bit of time
and check out if any of the
apps which we reviewed are
ready to become part
of the collection.
And as soon as we have a couple
of guys in there, then
we'll tell you guys all about
where you can find it.
And we'll definitely be making
a big deal of it then.
So right now it's a call for
nominations, basically.
So if you've had your app
reviewed by us and you've
already made awesome updates,
please let us know so we can
check it out.
And then anyone who we review
in the future, same thing.
As soon as you're ready for us
to take a look and give it the
App Clinic stamp of approval,
we'll go through that process.
And we'll let you all know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In general, the
way collections work is we can
link to them from our
website at any time.
And they have the ability to
be featured on Google Play,
but they're almost never
featured for a very long time.
So we can't guarantee that the
collection will appear on the
Google Play Store at any
particular time because that's
a merchandising team decision,
but we can tell you that it
will always be available
for you developers
to take a look at.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So we'll be pointing at it and
there will always be a link
that you can point at too.
And I should point as well
the thing about these--